if ain't broke don't fix it back with
animation junkie and something that I
wanted to talk about I really since I
started doing this subseries but you
know it's taking me a long time to get
through these because I'm kind of only
doing about one a month but I want to
talk about ghost in the shell this was
the movie that made me initially wake up
and pay attention to anime as an art
form and for a very long time stood as
my favorite anime film of all time that
did get supplanted eventually but it's
still right up there for me and I'm
actually gonna double dip slightly
because I haven't gotten around to
talking about the movie but what's
making me do this video is I have
finally seen I've been made for a while
goes to the show 2 point 0 which was
kind of a remastering of it so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to talk about
the movie generally mainly just talking
about its original release and then I'll
sort of have a little bit at the end
talking specifically about ghost in the
shell two point oh so close to the shell
if you didn't already know is a seminal
1990s cyberpunk anime film it was highly
influential on the matrix and if you
watch it and you've probably seen the
matrix and you watch this movie you can
see so many of the influences on that
film it deals with this specialized
security department in a near future
Japan dealing with the team hunting a
criminal known as the puppet master and
what he does is he hacks people's brains
because at this point in time people at
the very least have internet connection
Jack's in their brains if not in fact
being fully augmented humans or having
an artificial brain doing all the
computing inside their head so you can
actually hack a person and he has been
doing that so section 9 is hunting the
puppet master in section 9 the field
work is headed by major Motoko Kusanagi
now she is the hero of the film but
section 9 as a whole is makes a really
good backup team now she is actually a
fully cybernetic body she's not a robot
she's got a human consciousness in there
but she is a completely artificial body
and she's reached a point when she
started asking a lot of philosophical
questions about herself like I have
these
memories and I have this belief that I
have a soul or what they referred to as
a ghost but is it real anymore because
that's the only thing that theoretically
makes me any different from just a
machine and she's asking these questions
about herself while she's helping track
down this criminal the puppet master and
just sort of the meaning of this
existential crisis with the sorts of
crimes that she's tried game down for it
all builds very well now I'm talking the
head of your concepts here initially
because there they are very much front
and center characters actually stop and
talk about some of the philosophical
implications of what is going on but
this is also an anime action movie and
the action is phenomenal it's brutal
really there's some really hard hitting
fights hand a hand gun combat there's
some gory deaths in this but what's
really interesting about it is even when
the action ramps up and if you would
avoid the action in isolation you kind
of get that your house sense to it but
the tone is still very somber I really
thought I chalk that up to the music the
music that is laid in especially during
the action scenes just keeps you in the
philosophical mindset even as you're
watching bullets flying especially in
the climax of the movie the music used
during the climax out which is a piece i
believe called floating museum is one of
my favorite pieces of music written for
the screen and the way it offsets
encounter points what you're watching
it's so not the kind of music you would
expect but it's perfect for what the
film has been building to up to this
point now obviously I've just kind of
been gushing the whole time up to this
do I have anything to complain about not
really there's a couple of nitpicks the
first is if you're gonna watch this as
an American or as an English speaker you
really need to watch it with the
subtitles because the dub the dub sucks
and you need to realize I it takes a lot
for me to recommend watching with the
subtitles on an animated film because
yet when it comes to live-action don't
watch the dub you know they're trying to
recruit not only to the lips not match
up but you know an actor in a booth with
just a microphone was trying to recreate
what the actor live on the set you know
felt and brought to the camera and
that's just not the same but when you're
dealing with animation the original
Japanese
actor was just a guy in a booth so you
can have an English voiceover actor
who's just a guy to booth give a good
proper voiceover the major fall down is
the woman who they got to do major
Motoko Kusanagi and she's just bad
especially when she has to talk for a
while about the philosophical concepts
it just doesn't work now that may end up
being a turn-off for some people that
I'm going to recommend watching with
subtitles because that is distracting
but I think it gets away with in this
film because when they do more talking
tends to be quieter tone down scenes but
you know the more action-oriented sees
tends to just be the action there's not
a lot of talking going on so I think it
works watching it with the subtitles and
I suppose the other thing is you just
got to be in the right headspace this is
a more philosophical piece it's got a
lot of slower paced moments it's still
an action movie it's got great action
set pieces and it does build to like I
said a phenomenal climax that i love but
this is not a rollercoaster of a movie
so if that's what you go in expecting
you're going to come away disappointed
probably annoyed so that's my general
feelings on the filming you can consider
that my spoiler free review getting into
ghost in the shell two point oh I am
going to more freely talk about spoilers
because I have to to talk about some of
the differences between the films I
before i get into the spoilers i will
say goes to the show two point oh don't
bother it is it is like star wars
special editions there's all these
changes that were made for either no
reason or a reason that I don't think is
enough to justify it and they didn't
even take the opportunity to redo a new
American dub on it skip it watch the
original getting into some of the
specifics there's a lot of changes that
went on that and some are just odd like
most of the computer stuff in the
original one that had a green tint to it
which is kind of typical certainly at
this point it's become almost a cliche
they've redone that to an orange tint
and then it's not like that Rex anything
but that's just an odd thing to change
especially because it changes the feel
of it Green is a very cool color orange
is a warm color that fundamentally
changes your emotional reaction to what
you're seeing some of the things they
did a lot of vehicles that were a
hand-drawn animation have been replaced
with CGI vehicles and that I'm its okay
its not an improvement
but it's not horribly integrated there
are a couple of scenes though where
major Kusanagi herself is replaced with
a CGI character and I don't understand
why at all the opening intro they do
this and then at the midpoint of the
movie where she's diving coming out of
the water they do it again and it it
looks wrong especially since the rest of
the movie she doesn't look like that but
when they insert in the middle
especially it looks like you know what
it looks like it looks like a cut scene
out of a video game it just looks wrong
it's jarring and there was nothing wrong
with the original animation there was
one change that they did that I found
kind of interesting but I still don't
like it and that was to the voice actor
doing the puppet master they went from a
male voice actor in the original to a
female voice actor in ghost in the shell
2 point 0 and I I'm not entirely sure
why they did this I have a theory though
the only reason that I can think that
you would do this would be if there was
some concern or some reaction that
having to be a male voice meant that
there was some sort of implied sexual
connection between the puppet master and
the major and I suppose especially with
what happens at the end which is that
they sort of merge and and this new
being emerges as a result of that and
the puppet master himself even says you
will give birth to a new intelligence I
suppose that if you were inclined to you
could read that as okay they just took
an independent powerful yes at times
visually sexualized woman but woman was
very much in control and they have
basically now said what makes you
important is your ability to give birth
and be a mother and so that could be
seen as diminishing of her character now
I've never read the movie that way up to
this point I only thought of that comes
I was trying to think of why they would
change the voice actor from a man to a
woman and I came up with that idea but
I've seen this movie a lot of times and
I never read it that way again I can see
how you can but I would are
against that even really being the case
in the first place but if that's what
they were trying to fix they kind of
cause some other problems the first is
is that one of the things I really loved
about that voice work in the original
was seeing that that woman android body
and hearing that deep male voice come
out of it it's disturbing it's
off-putting it's creepy and it works and
then more logistically towards the very
end right before they merge when the
major and the puppetmaster are
communicating and it's just basically
just their brains talking to each other
so neither on characters mouth is moving
in you're just hearing the voices
instead of hearing a male voice and a
female voice you're now hearing two
female voices I'm not going to say that
I literally could not tell the
difference then there was slight
differences but they were similar enough
that I had a much harder time and it
only it took me a second to figure out
who was talking at a number of points
and that's distracting so yeah like I
said goes from the show to point o skip
it no point but ghost in the shell
definitely see it if you haven't if you
like anime at all you haven't seen this
get off your button actually you may be
interested to check it out anyway
because it is being remade as an
American action will be Scarlett
Johansson's got to be the major I do
have my eye on this and I have mixed
feelings the more that I hear about it
but I'm hopeful we'll see in any case
those are my thoughts on both coasts of
the shell and ghost in the shell 2 point
0 have you seen one or either version of
this movie what were your thoughts on
what was your preference did you like
the changes where you're like me did you
hate them whatever your thoughts about
either version or this movie as a whole
or the remake or whatever drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it please feel free to like
subscribe follow me on twitter at
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast on itunes and stitcher
and as for me I'll be back as soon as I
can get my next fix